and joining us right now is the ceo of
one of the rare instances
of a team being five and six still in
the mix for a playoff spot
and potentially being more resilient
than the team that went to the super
bowl last year
what a season for the san francisco
49ers and uh good friend of the program
the ceo of the team jed york joining me
here on the show how are you jed
i'm i'm good rich thanks for having me
man you bet uh so your team is currently
they flew to arizona
last night correct yes okay so they are
there right now and they're there for
two weeks and interestingly enough of
your five games remaining you play in
that building three times two is the
as the home team and one is the away
team right that's fine
i think we're there for at least three
weeks we'll stay there before we play
dallas as well
okay we'll travel from arizona to dallas
so
i mean our hope is that santa clara
county uh
lifts its restrictions which which they
said was going to be december 21st so
we're hopeful that we can come home the
week at christmas but
you know obviously everything is going
to remain in the air
until we see where the the the number of
coveted cases and hospitalization rates
and things like that go
now look uh jed uh the the situation
could not be more sensitive i understand
that because
every team in the national football
league wants to be part of the community
and a good neighbor
and you know but you also want to be
home you
you've got a competition here and you
also have players who want to be home
with families and
home for as you mentioned uh the
holidays as opposed to going straight
from dallas back to arizona to prepare
to be the road team in that game so how
how did this all come about
can you walk me through how this then it
talks with santa clara county
i mean this talk started obviously back
in march
and working with with the nfl protocols
and things like that and getting the
company comfortable and up to speed with
what the nfl and the 49ers were doing
and as cases started to rise you know
we've had conversations with the county
you know they wanted to put you know in
sort of a soft bubble so to speak in a
place
and we've been talking to them for about
a week about doing that
um but they they made the decision
obviously with their
their announcement publicly as we were
boarding our buses to go to la that
that they were shutting down not just
you know
sports but but a lot of other businesses
and a lot of other things
so we you know after working with them
for a week we're a little blindsided by
that
but obviously the the health and safety
of
of the community is the most important
thing and like anything in football
you know you you get thrown you know
obstacles in your way and we had to
come up with with an answer fairly
quickly so when you say soft bubble
because my colleague mike garfulo
of the nfl media group and nfl network
discussed it
uh on air yesterday that agents of
players on your team were telling him
that
uh management of the 49ers had broached
the idea of a soft bubble and that they
were
into it until santa clara county made
its decision what what is
that soft bubble idea that you were
forwarding to the players i mean
there were a lot of things that that
were in place um
i mean essentially just keeping our
players you know at the facility
at levi's for games and then being able
to go
to to away games and that was
essentially all we were allowed to do
and not just players i mean me included
our coaches our staff um and we were
willing to do that and the players are
willing to do that to be able to stay
with their families
um you know obviously there's
everybody's sacrifice
this isn't just the 49ers it's not just
us everybody is obviously sacrificed
throughout this
pandemic but our guys were willing to do
that to stay with their families
um and unfortunately that wasn't able to
remain in place
and that's why you know thinking about
the future i'm hopeful that we're home
by december 21st and if not
we've been working with our players in
the league and trying to figure out
um a safe way to be able to get players
families
to them in arizona obviously if we're
not allowed to
return home so um a lot of moving parts
my word
so uh yeah there are so so
again it could not be more sensitive
because you want to be home for
christmas
and your home is in santa clara county
uh and you said you were a little
blindsided so how do you have talks with
a county that um it seems from what
you're saying
let it be known to the world before you
know reaching out to you
that you know how to find a new place to
go
i mean honestly like we we we can't take
offense to it that
there there's more people in santa clara
county than just the san francisco 49ers
um so obviously the folks that they're
affected the most the frontline workers
the nurses the doctors
people that are dealing with this every
day it's not just us
so obviously whatever the county needs
to decide to figure out what
what they think keeps everybody safe
we we will abide by um and and we have
to
we have to deal with that so i mean this
isn't i don't think that they tried to
single out the 49ers
and and do something to harm the 49ers i
think they're trying to make the right
decisions for the county
and unfortunately as cases rise in santa
clara county
we we had to make adjustments and i
couldn't be more proud of our players
for for making those adjustments or more
thankful to
michael bidwell and the cardinals and
the entire state of arizona
for opening their their arms of
welcoming us and
you know thankfully they have nfl ready
facilities
and our home schedules match up well
with with the cardinals so we can
we can actually make the most of it and
go somewhere and and hopefully finish
out the season strong
so um and on that front was there any
consideration given to
um staying closer to home for you
uh like the the old raider stadium
in oakland or maybe the home of the san
francisco giants or anything like that
was any consideration given to that
we we talked to uh the mayors of both
oakland and san francisco and they were
extremely helpful but but obviously it's
not just their decision
you know the the county health officials
are the ones that ultimately are are
making decisions right now
and it was it was very prohibitive for
us to be able to do that
especially with having to travel outside
of the county and come back and with the
quarantine that's in place
it just it wasn't going to work and we
certainly weren't going to skirt any of
the guidelines
and you know you know not abide by the
county guidelines if we came
back into the county you're supposed to
quarantine in your house for 14 days
and that obviously wouldn't wouldn't be
feasible if we left
so knowing that this could go through
december 21st and potentially longer
we we needed to find another alternative
you know the mayor of san diego
offered up a lot of help um which would
have been fantastic
unfortunately there wasn't a stadium for
us to be able to plan in san diego
and that's why arizona end up becoming
the the best
option of obviously not not the easiest
situation to deal with
49ers ceo jed york joining me here on
the rich eisen show okay then so
um do you think that your
stay in arizona to use a phrase i guess
uh you already did this in west virginia
in between weeks two and three between
your jets and giants games
uh the patriots are coming out here to
los angeles and i'm assuming going to
stay out here as well do you think
these situations bubbling up soft
bubbles however you want to put it
is something that could potentially be a
test case for the nfl when the playoffs
roll around for
all nfl teams i know in talking with dr
sills and the commissioner i mean
they're they're looking at everything
right now i think our protocols are
working fairly well obviously there are
some teams that have
had coveted issues but i think they've
done a very good job of containing it
within the teams
and you know it that that's a decision
that i wouldn't make
i wouldn't be you know privy of making
but i think the league is going to look
at anything that that takes place
and whatever they feel like is going to
keep our players as safe as possible
and and give us the best chance of you
know finishing the season getting
through the playoffs
i'm sure anything and everything is on
the table i think roger said that
yesterday before the
the steelers ravens game right i think
everything's on the table
and you know at least now instead of you
know hypothetically saying does a bubble
work and does this work
you know you'll at least have a sense of
this is what the 49ers are doing
is there a place to do that i know
talking to kevin demock before the game
uh last week you know la is fortunate
enough to have multiple
stadiums that play host to big events
whether it's the rose bowl the colosseum
obviously the the beautiful stadium and
so far
you know i mean he's talked about a
potential soft bubble
in in la as a as an alternative for the
playoffs
so i mean i think there are a lot of
options out there and
you know people that are much smarter
than me and and actually
understand infectious disease and and
obviously the safety that comes with
that
they'll be the ones making the decisions
and we just need to be prepared to
execute whenever
whenever we're called on but yeah i mean
come on you're smart yet you went to
notre dame
um so uh you know uh but put it all
together
in the country i i can't remember how's
your team doing
come on jed you walked right into it i
walked right into it but i wanted a
front i just wanted to get it out of the
way
you know we're having a very a real
conversation we're having a real
conversation but there has been an
elephant in the room the entire time
i just wanted to address it before
moving on out of the irish
but the conversations amongst ownership
though
uh a week 18 and and and
pushing playoffs and pushing the super
bowl back what
what what are those conversations that
you're willing to share that you've had
that fans are wondering about as we're
watching
certain games being played on time
despite
uh roster uh problems for teams
you had one of them on a thursday night
a few weeks ago against green bay and
other games being
pushed like the thanksgiving game so
what what has been discussed that you're
willing to share with us here amongst
ownership about
um moving things around for the playoffs
and the end of the season
i mean i think i think they have
flexibility i i don't know
you know what all the flexibility is but
there certainly seems to be flexibility
um to be able to move things around if
need be and i know for us
you know you you reference the thursday
night game against green bay we had a
false positive with kendrick born
and you know two or three close contacts
with starters you know you lose another
starting receiver a left tackle
and it's easy to complain but you know
those are
those are the rules it was set out very
clearly from the beginning
and the nfl is going to do everything
that they can to
number one make sure that people are
safe and that you know you're not
transmitting covet on the field and
to my knowledge there hasn't been a
single case of transmission
on the field um and i know that we all
have to be flexible i'm hopeful that we
are
in a playoff conversation and you know
if they want to put us a bubble
in a bubble anywhere i i'm sure our guys
would sign up for it if they want to
just
erase the next five weeks of the season
and give us a better opportunity
to uh defend the nfc crown that we
that we won last year but you know we
have no idea what's going to take place
and i know that the nfl and
dr sills and all the infectious disease
people that they're talking to
they will have multiple options for us
and they'll
they'll put us in a position that it's
going to be as safe as possible so how
does that work
like everybody zooms together and and a
decision gets made amongst
the 32 members are interesting
people that zoom is probably not their
their technology of choice it's it's fun
to see who's on
and and how they do it and i mean
i i i won't name names so when you have
people calling out other people on zoom
and they think they're on mute it's
it's pretty entertaining no come on
that's how jed that's happened
you're seeing a member of the national
football league has talked about another
member of the national football league
thinking they have muted on zoom and
they have not
that's what you're saying to me right
now i i mean i i i may be intimating
that
that that could be correct it's funny
i i i wish that the zooms were broadcast
like
also oh my so do i
all right this is out of all the news
that we might be talking about right now
that to me is
uh what uh what does the what does it
rhyme with
i i'm not gonna go there but it's you
know i mean i
it's it's hard to communicate you know
when
you've got 32 teams and you know folks
are on zoom like it's just not the
easiest thing to do
and generally we are a committee driven
league
yes um so the committees i think are
doing great work
that's a little bit easier to do on zoom
and to do sort of separately
but it's it's been challenging to bring
everybody together like
everybody else is dealing with you know
it's hard to bring
a large group of people and in the nfl
when you have 32 owners and a
commissioner and
you know people that work at the league
office you have a lot of important
people that that want to have their
voices heard
and it's it's challenging that's why
that's why i brought it up jett is that
because
these are decisions that might have to
be made in real time on the fly
things are happening i mean as fans are
watching week in and week out
covert 19 list this player is on it that
player is on it this person's off with
that person's offer this game is going
to have to be played even though a team
like yours
was without uh a left tackle the
starting quarterback was already hurt i
mean
it could have helped to have that game
for you pushed two games
we have to make sure that that health
and safety is the most important thing
and you know again our protocols are in
place our guys know what the protocols
are
and you know you just have to live with
those consequences
and i don't know that it would have made
a difference obviously green bay is
rocking and rolling right now i
i hope that it would have made a
difference but but i don't know
i hope we get an opportunity to play
those guys again what's it like being
the owner of
because you you're hearing you're
hearing so many other teams talk about
scheme this scheme that you know that
the scheme doesn't fit
and your coach is a a master schemer
what's that like we're we're just we're
very fortunate to have john and kyle
together
those guys are great and you know one of
our one of our beat reporters matt
mayoka asked me earlier today
um about you know the the the coach in
gm that we're going up against
and coach mcdermott and and brandon bean
who we
also interviewed when we hired kyle and
john and those two guys
are doing a heck of a job you know
they're on the same page
kyle and john are on the same page and
it it speaks volumes like
i mean you you have no idea what your
opponents are going to be throughout the
season you don't know if you're going to
have
a pandemic to deal with you don't know
if you're going to be you know forced to
leave your home and go somewhere else
for
weeks or potentially five weeks at a
time you have no idea
and that's very very hard not to mention
you have to play
you know great teams on on sundays or
monday nights or whenever we're playing
and have john and kyle there together
knowing that they're on the same page
battling through all this stuff together
it it it definitely helps you sleep at
night well i mean
and and for you too you know uh you went
through a period there where you were
one and dunning and not
not because that was your plan at all
but but you've got this in place
and you're coming off of what you came
off last year and your team is at five
and six still in this mix with
a possibility to get some of your guys
back um what is that like for you
jed seriously like i mean this season
you know i mean i go back to a
conversation i had with with the
governor of california gavin newsom
and i said look this isn't about you
know financial
results for us this year like if it was
about finance
and and the bottom line i'd ask you to
cancel the season because we would
financially be better off
not playing but there's no possible way
that the 49ers weren't going to do
everything that we could
to defend the nfc west championship
defend the nfc championship last year
and knowing that you know people look
forward to
sundays they look forward to monday
nights they look forward to thursdays
and even sometimes wednesday afternoons
you know the the nfl is such a big piece
of of our country
you know 20 percent of americans watch
an nfl game
on sundays you know a third of the
country watches the super
bowl like we we wanted to make sure that
we did everything that we could to play
this season
and watching our guys go through
all of this stuff i mean raheem mostert
i don't know if you saw him
oh he talked about it that was i mean
raheem summed it up like you know i mean
our guys
i realize that that our players make
more money than than
average american but they also work for
maybe four to five years
and guys need to make decisions on what
they want to do
and he made the decision to to step away
from his family to try to keep them
safe and and go to go to work
you know and if you can't respect that
and the same way that you have to
respect the way a nurse
leaves her family or his family to go in
to help other people like there's a lot
of people that are doing those things
right now
and you know you just have to be proud
of them and you have to be proud to
to see the team come together
under very very adverse circumstances
chad
appreciate the time uh so much so i'm
going to leave you with a suggestion
okay because i like making uh guests and
guests who i appreciate
uh better than when i found them okay
i'm gonna make you a suggestion here
okay jed
you can go to graduate school in
michigan no no no no no no
i wasn't sure no no no no actually it's
this is you know
something i'm still going to suggest
making you better despite that swipe
um uh uh you can take this
uh and use it or not but you i imagine
when you are in the home of the arizona
cardinals you as the home team will have
control of the
the the scoreboard and everything right
this is your this is your home
team they're going to be they've been
awesome about all of them so
right when the bills come out you put
the hail murray up there
and you're just blasted okay because
they're gonna be a little spooked coming
back in that building
you know i know it's a new building for
you as a home team but you've been there
before
bill's yeah the whole thing the whole
the whole the whole thing the the sound
full of the call
you put kyler murray to deandre hopkins
up there and just
keep rolling it over and over again as
they're on the field
it may frighten us too because we've got
to be there in four weeks not only those
guys no i know that i know that but
it's one week at a time league you know
that jedi it is
just survive in advance move on how how
fired up do you think chris berman is to
watch the niners and the bills play this
i don't even think of boomerang circle
the wagons
[Music]
it was his super bowl pick for like 15
years straight
he was right most of the time and
bloomer will be on at halftime in that
game i'm sure you've just given him out
he probably had that idea anyway i'm
sure i'm sure jed thanks for the call
you take care appreciate it guys stay
safe
and i hope to be in person soon you got
it that's the jed york the ceo of the
san francisco 49ers
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here